[Music]
good morning John is Monday September
17th
Danny was 9 when his dad left it was
sudden and nasty and mostly just sad it
seemed like he left immediately like 1
week the volume of conversation started
increasing and the next week
tranquility was abandoned completely and
then they all just cried for hours they
just held each other and cried and then
he was gone his mom wouldn't tell them
what happened only that he might come
back maybe in a year to slowly talk
filtered into Danny's ears talk about
his father's lapse in religious vows
talk about his mother swinging from the
path and finally talk of other women
mistresses that Danny had always
imagined his little Asian women in red
silk dresses his mom of course never
said anything about it but she didn't
deny it either
so Danny sifted through it all and
pulled out what still made sense at
first he couldn't imagine his father
with other women but then after a few
years he'd started to imagine himself
with some other women and his
perspective had shifted maybe she was a
Buddhist from birth maybe she was
Chinese like his father unlike his
mother reminding him of home and faith
in of the path maybe the divorce really
was about religion that at least would
explain the big and induced sobbing it's
okay mom it's not that big of a deal he
was popping up at the can getting ready
for the losing my religion talk he could
handle that your dad didn't leave me it
was a funny thing for her to say but
Danny bit his tongue before pointing out
the obvious I mean he left he's gone I
mean but there wasn't a woman there
wasn't anything we just we only got him
for 10 years that was the deal the deal
was all that Danny could manage I wasn't
I'm not supposed to tell you your father
he graduated from the priesthood at a
young age he was still young when they
sent him to the border to a mission
that's where I met him Danny stared
his parents on the border his father
some kind of powerful and respected
priest his mouth must have hung too low
because his mom finally laughed I know
how could your lame old mom be an
exporter skid well I wasn't there long
and somehow when I left he came with me
there were well there were problems with
him leaving he was devastated but I
didn't want to live that life and he
needed to leave the mission he got out
but only for 10 years it was the only
way he kept telling me that he said it
until I believed it and then we came
back here and we lived and we raised you
and then just like he said one day he
told me the time was coming and a month
later he was gone so he's there in
border town I can go see him Danny had
no idea how much he wanted to see him
until he realized that he was out there
I can go there I'm I'm old enough to
work the machine myself he said as he
caught sight of his mom's eyes she
looked so sad not all the time I still
have to go to school maybe just during
the summers don't worry mama
I won't abandon you a smile that he
didn't know he had enema spread across
his face his father a famous Buddhist in
the most exciting city in the world and
his mom crying again worse than before
worse than he'd ever seen
she gripped the table with white
knuckles and shook and sobbed the smile
faded it wasn't going to be okay Danny
saw it coming but he wasn't prepared
between her sobs he heard her say it
he's dead he died they killed him how
could it hurt so bad to lose something
you'd already lost Danny looked down in
his cold tortilla I'm going to border
town